[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias e historias de nuestro
continente esto es lo que veremos hoy la
política exterior de joe biden a prueba
por la atención en medio oriente los
progresistas del partido demócrata lo
presionaron para que le exigiera israel
un cese del fuego a cambio de mantener
las ayudas económicas presión que al
parecer dio fruto el 6 de junio los
mexicanos eligen a 500 miembros de la
cámara de diputados así como a 15
gobernadores y más de 20.000 cargos
públicos en las elecciones más grandes
de su historia les contamos como las
personas trans intentan ganar un lugar y
dos reformas y dos ministros caídos pero
las protestas antigubernamentales siguen
en colombia el paro nacional consolidó
su poder luego de que el proyecto de
reforma a la salud fuera archivado en el
congreso las manifestaciones pacíficas
continúan para pedir reformas de fondo
que acaben con la inequidad social
y vamos de inmediato a eeuu para nuestra
historia principal
el presidente joe biden enfrentó a una
inmensa presión desde su propio partido
para que tuviera una posición más
contundente que llevara un cese del
fuego en medio oriente el ala
progresista demócrata le pidió que
condicionará a los cuatro mil millones
de dólares en ayudas que la unión
americana le otorga a tel aviv a cambio
de que detuviera los ataques aéreos una
presión que al parecer funcionó con el
anuncio del jueves de una tregua
unilateral desde su llegada a la casa
blanca su vaivén dejó claro que quiere
voltear la página de las políticas de su
predecesor en términos diplomáticos
esto significa priorizar los derechos
humanos es música para los oídos del ala
progresista de su partido que es
particularmente activa sobre el
conflicto palestino-israelí
alexandre a ocasio cortes comparó la
situación con el apartheid y fue una de
las demócratas que presionó a bailén a
revisar el apoyo incondicional de
washington a las acciones de israel al
solo dar un paso para nombrar las
acciones de hamás y negarse a reconocer
los derechos de los palestinos
by then refuerza la idea de que
palestinos instigaron este ciclo de
violencia esto no es lenguaje neutral
esto es tomar partido tomar el lado de
la ocupación
esther el 12 de mayo 25 demócratas
firmaron una carta en la que llamaban al
secretario de estado- anthony blinken a
presionar a israel con el fin de evitar
los desalojos de los palestinos de
jerusalén este para joe biden es un acto
de equilibrio difícil entre la izquierda
y el centro de su partido y al mismo
tiempo evitando un conflicto con los
republicanos enfáticamente pero
israelíes
está a la izquierda en el corazón del
partido demócrata está hecha para los
jóvenes para las mujeres para los hijos
de inmigrantes y para aquellos que
ayudaron a derrotar a donald trump
y les elección parcial a nivel estatal
y hay que considerar las elecciones de
medio término él necesita la mayoría así
que yo bailén tiene que evitar ofender a
su a la izquierda
el congresista
yo bailé en camino en una línea delgada
con un enviado especial en la zona pero
bloqueando las declaraciones de la
organización de naciones unidas llamando
al fin de la violencia y no asaltado a
tratar de lograr un acuerdo de paz como
lo hizo donald trump pero su
vicepresidenta kamala harris si reiteró
el compromiso de la administración a una
solución de dos estados y en el corto
plazo a una tregua que pusiera fin a los
bombardeos aéreos que dejaron más de 200
palestinos muertos en 10 días
[Aplausos]
vamos a méxico que está en la recta
final para las elecciones del 6 de junio
las más importantes de su historia
debido a la magnitud más de 94 millones
de personas están convocadas a las urnas
para elegir a 500 diputados federales y
a casi 20.000 cargos estatales la
comunidad lgtb de pumas busca un lugar
entre todas esas oportunidades para
continuar luchando por la consolidación
de sus derechos en el país
norteamericano entre ellos están las
personas trans tan solo para la cámara
de diputados hay 40 candidaturas veamos
desafiando la discriminación luchando
contra los estereotipos combatiendo el
conservadurismo de las personas trans
buscan hacer historia en unos comicios
que ya se estiman memorables y son
decenas las candidaturas que prometen
trabajar por los derechos de la
comunidad lgbt y más se obtienen un
lugar en las elecciones del 6 de julio
lo único que buscamos es ya que nosotras
como trans podamos ser más visibles en
partidos políticos en las asambleas en
esta parte más más social o sea que lo
que nos digan ah pues ya tenemos el
derecho a tu cambio de nombre y al
cambio de tu que tengas matrimonio
igualitario ya está y conformarte no
nosotros también queremos seguir
avanzando porque el hecho de nos de ser
una mujer trans no nos impide poder no
levantar la mano leidy tacos de canasta
indígena que vende comida en las calles
de ciudad de méxico se identifica como
mucho el tercer género del grupo de mico
zapoteca ganó fama tras enfrentarse a la
policía que trató de desmantelar su
venta de tacos
con 36 años espera llegar a la asamblea
de la capital mexicana para ayudar a
mejorar los servicios de salud para la
comunidad y por supuesto protección para
los vendedores callejeros vale la pena
porque hay gente por la cual si estuvo
esperando este momento hay gente que sí
que necesita que alguien la represente y
que la voz de nuestra voz sea escuchada
entonces
te digo más allá de lo que ya ganamos no
ya abrimos esta puerta que era lo que
estábamos buscando
fernanda pereyra espera a ser la primera
gobernadora transexual de mexico y
facilitar el derecho a la identidad de
género a sus paisanos que para cambiar
de nombre y género en documentos
oficiales debe ir a otro estado
ahorita el momento es para la
visibilidad para darse a notar para ver
que se está contando pero estos pequeños
pasos van a hacer que al rato ya los
pasos sean por sí solos estamos
demostrando que somos como cualquier
personaje somos como cualquier ciudadano
hasta ahora solamente una persona
transgénero ha logrado ser elegida para
un cargo público en mexico rubia araujo
que en 2016 se convirtió en la primera
regidora trans del municipio de
guanajuato sin embargo méxico es el país
latinoamericano con mayor representación
l gmt y q más en el congreso según una
investigación de distintas latitudes que
revela que la comunidad ha logrado 22
congresistas en la región distribuidos
entre mexico con 41 en guatemala' aruba
costa rica ecuador bolivia y chile y al
menos 2 en venezuela colombia
si el perú uruguay y argentina
vamos al sur del continente para revisar
otras noticias de las américas esta
semana argentina deja de exportar carne
durante 30 días como medida para
combatir el aumento de los precios en el
mercado interno que durante 12 meses
subieron un 65%
los productores convocaron a una huelga
para rechazar la iniciativa del
presidente alberto fernández
en brasil la policía federal inició una
investigación contra el ministro de
medioambiente por presuntamente
facilitar la exportación ilegal de
madera a europa y eeuu se trata de un
hombre cercano al presidente ya ir
bolsonaro al tiempo la corte en suprema
suspendió a otros diez funcionarios de
esa cartera como parte de las pesquisas
y medios de comunicación colombianos
informaron que falleció alias jesús
santrich uno de los ex jefes de la
desmovilizada guerrilla de las farc los
hechos habrían ocurrido en territorio
venezolano en la frontera con colombia
el gobierno colombiano no ha confirmado
la muerte pero las disidencias de las
farc si una semana antes de conocerse la
noticia a la corte suprema de colombia
había avalado la extradición de sant 3 a
estados unidos por delitos de
narcotráfico
y nos quedamos en colombia porque las
calles se volvieron a llenar de gente en
la cuarta jornada de paro nacional desde
el 28 de abril los colombianos han
salido a protestar principalmente de
manera pacífica pero al margen de las
manifestaciones se han registrado actos
de violencia especialmente a manos de
las fuerzas de seguridad según han
corroborado organizaciones defensoras de
los derechos humanos como human
rightswatch en hechos que dejan al menos
50 muertos hasta ahora el paro nacional
ha logrado que la reforma tributaria la
que motivó las manifestaciones en primer
lugar fuera archivada así como la
renuncia del ministro de hacienda y de
la canciller y su triunfo esta semana
fue que el congreso archivará otra
reforma la del sistema de salud que
pretendía privatizar un sector de por sí
altamente tercerizada sin embargo las
manifestaciones continúan al margen de
un diálogo entre el comité organizador
de la huelga nacional y el gobierno que
está estancado uno de los reclamos
precisamente es el fin de la violencia
policial antes de cualquier negociación
y es que las protestas son
principalmente pacíficas y de hecho se
expresan de manera artística como
podemos ver en el siguiente informe
los últimos preparativos antes del
concierto que promete ser una revuelta
homero corteses el fundador de la
principal escuela de percusión en bogotá
y desde el inicio de las protestas su
banda ha marchado casi todos los días
los tambores de ahí ya generan mucha
alegría y una energía muy positiva
liberamos en otra sintonía quienes
tocamos y quienes están alrededor de 100
tambores con un mensaje se moviliza a
nuestros tambores la indignación por la
violencia hizo crecer al movimiento
antigubernamental tanta indiferencia
tanta injusticia todo es a las malas
todo es a punta de bala cuantos cuántas
décadas nos llevan matando líderes
sociales
[Música]
todos los días en bogotá hay
manifestaciones espontáneas y los
bloqueos de las calles se improvisan
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la mayoría de los colombianos apoyan el
paro nacional y tenemos
[Aplausos]
estamos acá
la fiesta empieza el ritmo de la
batucada
[Música]
sabemos que las cosas están cambiando y
pueden cambiar más
[Aplausos]
al día
cada vez más ciudadanos se suman al
reclamo por la renuncia del presidente
iván duque y un cambio de modelo
económico y social incluso si significa
ir hasta el final y enfrentar más
violencia
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américa recuerden que pueden
seguirme en redes sociales en la
dirección que viene en sus pantallas
cuídense mucho y sigan viendo france24
[Música]
porque la historia